hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by vessi and
we will be discussing
beachbody's best-selling diet product
shakeology
now before we get into it i want to talk
to you about these awesome
new shoes from bessie i feel like i've
bought so many shoes
over the years that promise to be
waterproof and fuss-free
only to step in like the tiniest little
puddle
and for them to be ruined for life
honestly
i'm a mom of two boys puddles are our
jam
but this vessy weekend shoe is 100
waterproof
sandproof slush proof and slip proof
so they keep my feet totally dry and
they're 100 washable for those really
muddy days
it's actually pretty crazy they're also
vegan
and made with dual climate knit material
that keeps them both
super comfy and breathable and they're
surprisingly stylish for every day
i basically wore these every single day
all fall long
and surprisingly i can still wear them
into the winter
with all of our canadian rain and slush
and snow
bessie has an incredible early holiday
sale offer right now so
you can use my link and grab yourself a
pair for the winter months while they
still have sizes
and you can thank me later if you missed
the sale use my code abby to get 25
off your vessy shoes and you can also
check out my disclaimer here on the
screen so feel free to pause the video
to read it
or check it out in the description below
along with a trigger warning
for some diet talk and of course don't
forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a video
all right now if you have been blessed
with the great honor of
never having heard of beachbody or
shakeology before
what a wonderful joyous life you must
live
but if you have any online presence at
all
you probably haven't avoided certain
friends and families
facebook posts waxing poetic about their
fitness journey
and how much a revolutionary wellness
program
has changed their life all while sharing
photos of them holding
a protein powder shaker bottle and
posing for
before and after shots the latter of
which
is always suspiciously in better
lighting
but anyway for my 90s kids beachbody
actually started out with popular dvd
workouts like p90x
and insanity but if you're not a
dinosaur like me
you might be more familiar with their
more current workout programs that you
can find on the world wide web
with names like 21 day fix 80 day
obsession or
clean week now before i dive into
shakeology
can i just acknowledge how cringe-worthy
the name
beachbody is for a body you know that
legit
anybody that is sitting on a beach is a
beachbody
like you don't have to train or diet or
completely alter your appearance
to gain that title you just have to park
your butt on a beach
something i'm pretty sure all of us
would kill to do
right now at this point in the pandemic
but anyways
let's take a look at shakeology's
sensationalized product claims
and what the research actually says
starting with a little history lesson
so once upon a time once upon a time
there was a lovely princess
shakeology was actually marketed as a
meal replacement beverage
now while i can't find any information
when this changed or why
the marketing now doesn't seem to
include that verbiage
and for good reason a meal replacement
needs to have
a minimum of 225 calories per serving
along with a specific amount of protein
among other things but now if you search
really effing hard you'll see a much
needed disclaimer
that by itself shakeology does not
replace a meal
great however the rest of the sentence
continues on to say
but it could be considered a healthy way
to tide you over
keep you from pigging out and help you
stay on course with your balanced
healthy
diet ugh really beachbody
like pigging out don't you mean
keep you from eating a normal amount of
calories for a healthy human being to
function
anyways today shakeology's key message
is to encourage people to drink it every
single
day in fact beachbody encourages that
you log your shakeology intake
and share your shakeology streak with
group members
to prove that you have been consuming it
day after day after day
and that's going to get expensive when a
month's supply will cost you 130
usd now while they do offer
both whey and vegan options and a range
of flavors including some seasonal
options like
pumpkin spice and peppermint mocha for
the purpose of this video
i will be focusing on their best-selling
chocolate plant-based vegan protein
powder
let's take a look at the six main claims
for this product
the first claim is around satisfying
your craving and healthy energy
now according to shakeology protein
fiber and beneficial carbohydrates
help to curb cravings and provide
healthy energy
shakeology is a low glycemic index food
low gi foods release carbohydrates more
slowly
causing a lower blood glucose response
protein and fiber help you feel full so
you eat less
which helps to support your weight loss
goals so
this is not untrue you hear it from me
all the time
we want to try to fill our meals and
snacks with the hunger crushing
combination
of fiber protein and healthy fats
and while research suggests that
macronutrient composition
is more important than the physical
state of food in determining subjective
appetite and food intake
other research suggests that hunger and
appetite
tends to be greater after eating a
liquid meal
compared to a solid one while hunger
hormones are
lower after eating the solid meal
there's also evidence that chewing the
act of chewing
helps to reduce self-reported hunger and
food intake
likely due to some alterations in gut
hormone responses
related to satiety finally evidence
suggests that eating more mindfully
at a slower pace and with an enhanced
focus on bodily sensations
increases awareness of satiety which in
turn can reduce
how much you eat and that is a lot
easier to do with
whole foods compared to a drink that you
can just
chug back so for reference one scoop of
shakeology
mixed with water contains just 160
calories
and 5 grams of added sugar which for
roughly the same amount of calories
fiber and protein you could eat 6 ounces
of greek yogurt
with 1 cup of mixed berries and have no
added sugar
having said that even with whole food
there's only so far that 160 calories
will take you
i mean even yogurt and berries are never
going to be more than a snack
so if you actually want to satisfy your
craving and
boost energy levels your body might just
need
more fuel the second claim is that
shakeology provides
lean muscle support they say protein
also helps you maintain lean muscle mass
and support muscle recovery
with 16 grams of protein from multiple
sources like flax
and peas shakeology is a well-rounded
protein source
providing all nine essential amino acids
again
this is all important however if this is
marketed as a post-workout snack to aid
in muscle recovery
you actually do want to pair it with
some carbs
a lot of carbs actually research
suggests that we ideally want
a three to one carbed protein ratio
post-workout
to help with replenishing glycogen
stores and to elicit an insulin response
that helps to drive the protein into the
muscle more efficiently
so many of these protein powders are
advertised as being so
low carb and low calorie but that's
actually not necessarily what your body
needs to support lean muscle mass
and muscle recovery after a workout so
since this product is currently just a
one-to-one ratio of carbs to protein
i would suggest just adding in some
berries or a banana to the smoothie
to just bump that up a little bit the
third claim is around shakeology for gut
health help
they say that probiotics prebiotics
fiber and digestive enzymes
help to support regularity and healthy
digestion
our formula has six grams of soluble and
insoluble fiber
as well as beneficial bacteria now when
looking at the ingredient list
it does state that this contains
bacillus coagulans
mtcc5856
which doesn't have in all honesty a lot
of research to support its use
it's also apparently got 200 million
cfus
which is a pretty good amount for a
fortified product but
some studies do suggest that you may
need as much as
10 billion cfus in a product to help the
bacteria survive until the end of its
shelf life
so if you're looking to include
probiotics in your diet
most fortified food-like products don't
have much of a clinical
dose so you may be better off adding
another supplement to your regime
this is not to say that the probiotics
in a lot of food products
are not good i mean a lot of these
things can add up throughout the day
however depending on your needs and your
goals
they may just not be quite enough now
although the digestive enzymes in
shakeology are not stated
individually in the ingredient list the
website does claim that the product
includes
six different forms alpha amylase
glucoamylase and alpha galactosidase
are included to aid in the breakdown of
complex carbohydrates
lactase and invertase to break down
simple sugars and carbohydrates
and cellulase to break down cellulose
now some of you may be familiar with the
anti-gas pill bino which is
alpha galactosidase or the magic pill
lactate
aka lactase that allows lactose
intolerance individuals
to consume dairy now while these two
supplements have been proven to be
beneficial for individuals that lack
enzymes
to comfortably digest these kinds of
foods or who have diseases of the
stomach or pancreatitis
there is no evidence to support that
digestive enzymes
have any real benefit to the average
healthy individual
there's also no evidence to support the
use of any of these other
mixed enzyme supplements the truth is
that our bodies naturally secrete
digestive enzymes
starting in the mouth and then down
again along the digestive tract
so shakeologies claim that the digestive
enzymes in the product
further break down molecules in the
drink to more efficiently absorb
nutrients into the body
has yet to be proven now the fourth
claim is that shakeology contains
free radical fighters superfoods like
camu camu and pomegranate
have antioxidant properties that can
help fight free radical damage
caused by the daily stresses of modern
living so it's definitely true that camu
camu and pomegranate do have amazing
antioxidant properties
but with no information on the relative
amounts of these ingredients
in shakeology it's probably a bit of a
hard sell
to assume that they'll do anything super
for
your health in fact if you look at the
nutritional panel
you'll see that the only antioxidant
that they've listed in significant
proportions
is vitamin c at 28
but just an fyi you could get over a
hundred percent of your vitamin c needs
just by eating half of a red pepper or a
cup of strawberries or brussels sprouts
it's really not that big of a deal
if you're eating a generally balanced
diet
you're probably getting enough now the
fifth claim
is around system support shakeology says
that vitamins and minerals
help your body's systems run smoothly
while superfoods and phytonutrients
such as matcha green tea and kale
support
vitality i mean
i feel like the word vitality has become
super popular as of late
to describe basically nothing concrete
or real it just sounds like something
you want right
i mean i believe it's just like a sexier
word for energy
but if that's the case uh yeah
any food with calories can give you that
and while i'm not sure what the deal is
with the kale other than the fact that
it's
always a good idea to throw some kale
into some marketing materials
matcha does of course contain caffeine
so i guess the statement
there when it comes to energy does make
sense
having said all of that if you look at
the ingredient list
kale and matcha are at the bottom of the
list
meaning they're probably present in
pretty undetectable quantities
but anyways moving on the last
shakeology claim
is stress busters so adaptogenic herbs
and botanicals have traditionally been
used to help the body adapt
and respond to the effects of stress
whether it's from your busy lifestyle
the environment
or working out our proprietary blend
includes unique ingredients like
ashwagandha
reishi and chaga which you don't usually
get from an ordinary
diet true uh
you don't normally get adaptogenic herbs
from an
ordinary healthy diet but
do you really need to uh
i mean while a lot of these mushrooms
and herbs have been used for millennia
in ancient healing practices even with
the most
studied adaptogen ashwagandha the
research is
pretty thin two small short-term studies
did find that using ashwagandha
supplements reduced cortisol levels
but ultimately we need much larger
sample sizes and timelines
to understand its long-term outcomes as
for reishi
and chaga some preliminary research
suggests that these mushrooms
may help to support the immune system
while stimulating
white blood cells but the research has
mainly been done
on immunocompromised individuals or
rodents
so it is really too early to make any
significant
sweeping claims here and again the doses
of these ingredients are not even listed
so
the likelihood of you getting a clinical
dose in the shake
is pretty slim bottom line shakeology is
an over hyped protein shake
padded with a ton of sensationalized
ingredients
with some additional nutrients fiber
antioxidants
and probiotics which is really nice but
because we don't know
all the dosages of these ingredients and
they're not listed
it's hard to know exactly what you're
drinking
personally i think it's totally fine to
drink this as a snack if you like the
taste
but it is absolutely not
a meal and it definitely shouldn't be a
meal
every single day or multiple times a day
the main benefit
of shakeology in my opinion is that it
can be easily grabbed for a quick snack
on the go if you've got like a really
super busy day
and preparing something just more
substantial
isn't gonna happen i mean we all have
those days
no shame there but do i think that you
have to drink it
to further your progress in your
beachbody workout program
or any wellness program
absolutely not but wait there's more
beachbody also sells shakeology boost
powder that you can add to your smoothie
which includes a formula for focused
energy power greens
and digestive health but if the original
shakeology was just so
perfect and complete why do we need to
add more to it obviously folks
it's so you'll spend more on a lot of
the exact
same ingredients do we really need to
double down on more caffeine
isolated fiber or dehydrated spinach
probably not so aside from the fact that
you can get
all of these benefits and a lot more
from
food that you chew are there any dangers
in taking a supplement like shakeology
not likely in this case
since according to their website
shakeology is
third party tested on consumerlab.com
but it is a good reminder when choosing
any supplement or protein powder
to check out websites like that or
labdoor.com or
nsf.org to really check out if a product
is being third-party tested
the bigger problem is with the concept
of multi-level marketing schemes in
general
like beachbody remember at the beginning
of the video i mentioned
beachbody coaches yeah
we need to talk about that so the way
that the company is structured is known
as an
mlm or multi-level marketing company
i've written about mlms and pyramid
schemes in a blog post before so
i will drop a link to that in the
description below if you're interested
but essentially coaches are independent
distributors
of beachbody products who have to sell
products
directly to people in their community
and they also make a commission
based on sales made by their recruited
downlines
hence the obnoxious facebook posts and
i'm using air quotes to describe
coaches because these are literally just
mlm sales people anyone can sign up to
be a beachbody coach
this means that there are typically a
lot of unqualified nutrition or fitness
individuals pushing shakeology products
plus the beach body fitness programs and
the meal plans and other miscellaneous
merch not only is it potentially
dangerous
taking nutrition information from a
rando online
but because they are literally sales
people for just
one brand it's not exactly unbiased
information either
when they make more money for every
shake that you drink
of course they're going to tell you that
having one or more shakes
every single day is vital to reaching
your fitness goals
so if you're following a beachbody
workout program and you love it
amazing but please be wary of
this tactic bottom line if you're
interested in trying a beachbody workout
program or
dietary supplement i strongly urge you
to talk to a registered dietitian
or health care professional first please
do not seek health advice from
coaches because they are not necessarily
looking out for
your best interest nor are they likely
qualified to be giving out nutrition
advice
in the first place ultimately there is
nothing inherently unhealthy about these
products in my opinion
so by all means enjoy them if you like
the flavor
and if they provide some easy convenient
nutrition for those busy days
but they are not a meal they are not
magic
and unless they help you create some
kind of caloric deficit
they will not inherently make you lose
weight
so on that note that is all for today's
video
thank you again to vessi for sponsoring
if you like this video please be sure to
give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with what you
want me to review next are there other
shady mlms or products that you want me
to take a look at
i'll do it for you subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye